Dean Blandino now Fox football rules
analyst here on the program how are you
Dean I'm good how are you I'm doing fine
all right let's get to this with the new
instant replay rule that allows coaches
to challenge offensive and defensive
pass interference but even more
importantly challenge when they think
one should have been called and one was
not what are your thoughts on this rule
Dean blending them the most significant
change that we've seen since they
brought replay back in 1999 and and this
is really a sea change because as
recently as last year the competition
committee was philosophically opposed to
reviewing these types of house and and
obviously the the play that occurred the
NFC Championship game was a was a
trigger for the conversation and it went
they went further than I think we all
thought it would they actually passed a
rule so this is this is a major major
deal and do you like it you know I think
it remains to be seen I you know I've
kind of come a long way in this area
with I'm not naive to sit here and say
that if we have the technology and we
have a mistake like one that occurred in
that game that we shouldn't try to fix
it and and I'm all for that and no one
wants schemes to to be decided on a
missed officiating call or non call and
and so you know I'm all for that I just
think the way this rule was put in again
last-minute scrambling to put language
together have we truly vented out all of
the you know and it's a it's a catch
phrase but it's true the unintended
consequences of this and I like look I'm
all for the coach if the coach thinks
that it's past appearance and he has a
challenge and he's willing to risk that
timeout
I'm all for that because it's limited
but now you open it up inside two
minutes and you have a replay official
who now has to in addition to knowing
what a catch is and and down by contact
and all those things they have to now
rule on past
that's that's going to be a challenge
now let me let's get to that then Dean
bland you know in the Honda insider
report because I didn't see any specific
language like egregious calls like
obviously the one in the NFC
Championship game crucial I mean there
was no language at all what are the
parameters for you think the the person
sitting in the art McNally Center in New
York City for the last two minutes what
are the parameters of buzzing in on OPI
offensive pass interference and DPI
defensive pass interference yeah so the
way the language is written it's it's
basically letter of the law they've just
added past an appearance to the list of
reviewable plays now they're gonna have
to figure out what the standard is and
again that goes back to putting
something in and putting the cart before
the horse now we got to figure out well
what is and what isn't going to be
creative and replay so the way it's now
it's letter of the law so if that
contact is early and we can see that on
video then it's a foul and and there are
a lot of things to consider there and
again inside two minutes are we going to
see more stoppages on these types of
plays and then certainly the potential
is there for that so there's as far as
you could tell will will there be do you
think there will be a directive whether
it comes from the Commissioner or Troy
Vincent who is in the front office in
charge of these things with your
successor at the position of of
officiating an al River on do you think
there's going to be a directive of don't
buzz in unless it's so clear and obvious
basically adding language that wasn't
put in by the competition committee and
voted on by the membership yeah I think
there will be there's always you put in
a rule change you write you put in
language in the book and then you figure
out what are the practical guidelines
and that's that's not that's not unusual
so I think there will be that directive
I know if I were in that position I
would want I would want that to be the
standard that it has to be clear and
obvious you certainly don't want you
know do we want to get involved in a in
a good defensive play and now we're
looking at whether he got his hand
on the receivers arm a split second
before the ball got there and now we're
going to create a 40-yard pass and the
parents I don't think anybody wants that
I think it has to be clear and obvious
and I wouldn't be shocked if again when
you put something in like this now you
have to work through all the details I
wouldn't be shocked that there's an
adjustment throughout the preseason what
we saw last year with roughing the
passer and we had to readjust in the
middle of the season so I think this is
going to be a fluid process yeah and
there's only one year for it I guess to
figure out all of that and then the
unintended consequences as you said Dean
what do you think give me some examples
of unintended consequences for this yeah
I think there's a couple of things you
know I was just listing a couple from my
own you know from my own self to ask
these questions I mean what if what if
there's a pass interference that's
called and now the ball is not catchable
can we review that can the coach
challenge that the ball wasn't catchable
what if it's called pass interference on
the field but the ball wasn't in the air
and and so can a coach now challenge hey
that there was a lot of contact but it
should have been illegal contact or it
should have been defensive holding
because the ball wasn't in the air can
we pick up that flag and now because
defensive holding an illegal contact
aren't reviewable you can't put that
part of it on so there's just so many
things to think through it's not going
to be as simple as yeah the Saints Rams
play great easy passing the parents put
the flag down let's move on but there
now they're going to be there's going to
be some situations they're gonna have to
talk through and figure out how to
handle because it could it has the
potential to get pretty common so let me
let me get on a couple of these here
that you just said so in the same way
that we can currently even before this
rule change that happened on on Tuesday
that you could review whether a ball was
tipped to waive off and a pass
interference penalty that's happened
right to say hey the contact is legal
because the ball was tipped the way that
you could have used replay for that
you're now saying
that replay could be used by a wily
coach that says pick up the flag for
pass interference because it was really
holding or illegal contact
let's review to see if whether the ball
had left the quarterbacks hand yet you
think that's something that's coming
down the pike yeah I think it is because
again the way the language is written
it's letter of the law pass interference
is reviewable well to have pass
interference the ball has to be in the
air the contact has to occur more than a
yard downfield it has to be a catchable
football so to me right now all of those
things would now be reviewable now the
inner Richard Sherman in me wants to
talk about the offensive pass
interference here yeah how do you think
this affects that because we're all
talking about the Saints play and the
fact that there's defensive pass
interference that could be called on
every pass play and wait till you see
the last two minutes what about
offensive pass interference with this
rule Dean house offenses often in my
time at the NFL you know there's there
were a couple of thousands that were
really difficult to officiate offensive
pass interference was one of them and
quite frankly it hasn't been
consistently officiated for years even
during my time at the NFL it's a
difficult play to officiate and that is
going to be another I think it's even
going to be a bigger challenge than dpi
because now you're getting involved in
you know did the defender has position
is the receiver initiating that contact
is he blocking downfield or is he trying
to run a route is the defender trying to
jam him there's you know did the contact
occur before the ball was touch did the
contact occurred more than a yard
downfield is it just hand fighting all
of these things that the official has to
to make that call in real time now it's
subject to review and you know we could
throw up can often too fast appearance
calls and not get a consensus on any of
them so it's going to be it's going to
be a big challenge and what about a time
frame I mean is it still in the last
again that that's the point of this in
the last two minutes because the OPI
stuff and the DPI stuff it still is
women's in the same
universe number of challenges that's
available to a coach we're talking about
the last two minutes how long obviously
that hasn't been changed at all but
usually we're not holding people's feet
to the fire that if we don't get a
certain response by a certain time we're
moving on what's the scoop on that Dean
well nothing has changed nothing's
changed regarding the rule in terms of
60 seconds to review the play the replay
official there's no limit to the number
of plays they can stop inside two
minutes so that's certainly that's
something they have to consider when
when you think about the standard I
don't think they want a whole bunch of
stoppages inside two minutes but nothing
else about the rule is changed so once
the game is stopped there's the time
limit the 60 second review and and then
they have to make a decision and again
it's going to you know New York is going
to get involved you have replay official
that's going to have to you know be
responsible for stopping the game and
initiating that review think about this
think about think about a scoring play
outside two minutes right and and the
replay official has to confirm that now
we have a touchdown and the replay
official says yes a touchdown but wait a
minute that receiver pushed off that now
becomes reviewable because that's under
their parameters and now we're going to
say okay we're confirming the touchdown
but guess what it was past an appearance
let's take it back and penalize the
offense ten-yard that the potential for
that there as well all right a few more
minutes left with Dean Blandino former
head of NFL refs now current Fox Sports
rules analyst here in the Honda insider
report what about the automatic replay
reviews being expanded includes scoring
plays and turnovers negated by a foul
why did why was that thrown into this
mix best you can tell as well yeah yeah
that was an unusual situation that's
where you have a scoring play you know
scoring plays are automatically reviewed
but I think a team submitted that to say
well it was a scoring play it was
negated by a foul why should we have to
waste a challenge that should be
automatically reviewed so I think that
was the theory behind that one but I
don't believe that passed so I don't
think that's going to be an
bell tolling oh it says right here the
effect also expands automated replay
reviews to include scoring plays and
turnovers negated by fouls but will
check on all of that yeah let's check on
that I wasn't sure yeah I know they
changed the tries as well so now all
tries will be with you yeah
automatically whether it whether they're
good or not all right so what can you
tell me of what you heard in the room
but about what Bella check and lead took
took the floor and wanted to hammer out
more the language I mean all the coaches
are seemingly in favor of this sort of
thing now Dean what did you get what's
going in the room the coaches got
together and and and we're pretty United
on this which which that's good that's
something obviously the coaches have a
strong voice and and they should be a
part of the rules change process and I'm
not sure they've had their their their
say in the past or at least you know the
way it's worked out the competition when
he goes through their their routine and
then we would present to the coaches on
the eve of the league meeting and it
really didn't give them a lot of time to
digest what was what was potentially
going to get get voted on so I think
that's good that the coaches got
together and hammered it out I just know
that I know that as recently as Monday
the competition committee was not
unanimous on this proposal I think the
competition committee was split as
recently as Monday but something changed
you know from Monday to Tuesday and
because the vote I believe was thirty
one to one with only Cincinnati and Mike
Mike Brown holding strong on his you
know his opposition to replay and
expanding replay being the the lone
dissenter
so again it was the coach I know the
Commissioner was was pushing for this
and and you know here we are what a rest
thinking today you know I can tell you
what I know there are 17 replay
officials out there that are that are
looking at the rulebook and trying to
learn pass interference now because it's
not something that they had to consider
you know I think the officials are
pretty good as it comes to replay it
doesn't change what they do they're
gonna go out I think that's the that's
the real key you know replay isn't they
replay is not a fix to a problem if you
think there's a problem on the field you
got to teach you got
train you got to get good direction so I
think the officials on the field this
doesn't change much for them they're
gonna they're gonna go out officiate the
games I think this this adds to the
replay officials plate and they're gonna
have to now bone up on on pass
interference and know what it is and
what it is and then be a part of that
how does that work part of those those
conversations you know that you know the
teaching tapes will go out and now when
when they when normally pass
interference tapes would go out to the
downfield officials and people that were
responsible for that
now replay is going to get involved and
they're gonna have to look at not just
what is and what isn't but what is the
standard here's an example of a call
that wasn't made and should be added in
replay here's an example of a call that
was made that should be taken off and
replay and I think that that has to be
the approach and just have to continue
to teach it so that there is up to speed
as possible when one machine can I make
a suggestion on this Dean yeah because I
always do that you know that Dean I
don't just I don't just sit here you
again the Tuck rule you were the one he
was the one that you kept on it and
pushing and eventually we got it done
and now look at the leak right look at
the league making billions everybody's
making billions
well not everybody look all right so
here's my suggestion there's 17 replay
officials that have to now do this right
as you mention 17 replay specials right
yeah if you get them all in a room you
do the cut up and you show it to
somebody they don't know that they're
gonna be the one to have to analyze they
have one minute to analyze is this past
interference or not and you say you
replay official three go and show them
the play and they got sixty seconds and
simulated cuz that's that's the issue
they don't know that they're gonna have
to do it until they have to do it and
they got to do it in 60 seconds go
is that the way it works yeah no I mean
there's they'll have clinics and they'll
get them all together in a room and
they'll go through plays and they'll go
through those types of expert in 60
seconds play yeah exactly you have to
put them up on yeah put them on the
clock because again you have to stop the
game now you have 60 seconds to make
that decision now once the game is
stopped New York will get involved in
that discussion as well you have the
referee that can look at it New York
will be involved so I think where the
replay officials really
to be critical is just initiating the
review and being aware that there's an
issue whether the call was made and
shouldn't have been or there should be a
call made that wasn't so I think that's
where they're they're really going to be
a key part of this process Dean thanks
for the call appreciate it
let's get you here in studio in Los
Angeles I got a million more questions
but this this this covers it for the
moment Thanks thanks brother appreciate
it all right you got ahead steam
Blandino Fox Sports the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience